okay a few other things to tell you
about today uh they the american rights
maga movement is continuing with the
just assassination talk
and it started with the search warrant
at mar-a-lago
with the idea that this is the precursor
to eventually assassinating donald trump
of course completely absurd
now they're just generally going into
the assassination of people
but the blame is being placed on the
biden administration and that's how i
mean when your brain rots like this
it's how you end up with steve bannon
telling marjorie taylor green during an
interview on real america's voice war
room
something like that
um steve bannon telling marjorie taylor
green
the biden administration is trying to
assassinate people
maybe the same people that have been
swatting me or apparently you got
swatted last night and i heard it i
heard it was a pretty big deal this is
who they are this matches up with
exactly what joe biden showed us last
night
and so you know the real question is are
any of us the the bethesda bethesda
speech the scranton speech what what uh
jean prier said at the thing about
extremism if you don't believe in in
their
rule that you're an extremist and what
he said uh it's all of a piece they're
trying to have people their political
opponents assassinated death by cop
now there's a couple different things
here
the swattings
the idea i guess that bannon is saying
is
when someone gets swatted which is what
happened to marjorie taylor green the
idea is someone calls the police and
says
oh i'm being held at marjory taylor
green's house the idea vaguely
extrapolated out fully would be the swat
team shows up and shoots marjorie taylor
green dead thinking that marjorie taylor
green is holding somebody hostage or
something that would be sort of the idea
now
the swatters are not the biden
administration and so the idea that the
biden administration wants to have their
political opponents assassinated seems
pretty wacky to extrapolate from the
facts but if you zoom out a little bit
what is happening here and their fury at
these speeches joe biden's various
speeches
is that the people who are against
democracy that's them that's steve
bannon marjorie taylor green when you
say trump really won and should be the
president that's factually incorrect and
it is a statement against democracy
democracy would be the person who won
gets to be the president the people who
are against democracy are furious
that biden called out
people who are against democracy
that's fundamentally what's going on
here the people who have laughed and
nodded along for years as trump said
lock that person up and lock this person
up and i really won the election and we
should we should um give the death
penalty for drug dealers and make me the
president even though i didn't win
now they are saying joe biden is being
really mean
and so
sadly this entire assassination thing
as they seem to be getting closer and
closer to rioting again right because
listen if trump's indicted they're going
to riot
they are making more and more claims
that the left is actually trying to kill
people so there's like three or four
different layers to this thing and of
course when we think about stochastic
terrorism in this country
it is perpetrated by the right almost
exclusively remember stochastic
terrorism is
you have an audience
and you go this is just an example you
go on every night and you go
they've got to do something about these
mexican immigrants someone's got to do
something about them
and if there's a
0.001 percent chance that someone in the
audience is going to take you literally
if there's a thousand people in your
audience it probably won't happen
if there's 10 000 people in your
audience it probably won't happen
if you've got a million or two million
people in your audience and there's that
0.000 you know whatever percent chance
and you keep saying every night
we've someone's got to take care of
these people whoever
now
it becomes statistically greater than 50
percent that someone in your audience is
going to go and do it and there's rarely
if ever legal liability for the
stochastic terrorists but that's been
the mo of the american right now
for a very very long time and we started
seeing this with glenn beck and others
during the obama era
i would argue even the bush era quite
frankly i'm trying to think back exactly
now
but
there's that and then there's the
projection of course
they are getting close to another riot
mark my words there will be violence
from these people if trump is indicted
which would be a completely legal
process
with all of the appropriate
legal eyes dotted and t's crossed um and
they are now talking about oh it's the
left that is about to be violent again
uh-uh not gonna happen it's gonna be
these people once again